je vous propose maintenant ce document
dans la région de bunia au congo ce
livre de violents combats les milices
utilisent depuis des années des enfants
de moins de 12 ans ces enfants soldats
qui portent des kalachnikovs ont reçu
une formation dès l'âge de dix ans des
enfants soldats qui ont appris à tuer
reportage éric meunier patrick desmulie
frédéric ranque
ils se disent redouter se croit
invulnérable à 10-12 présent ils ont
pour modèle les héros des films d'action
américains peu comme tous les enfants du
monde
mais eux ne jouent pas les simbas les
lions en swahili c'est le nom de cette
unité m qui campe ici aux portes de
bunia l'ennemi lendou est à 2 km ou bien
de 7
on ne sait pas très bien de ses enfants
perdus thomas est le plus érudit le seul
à avoir suffisamment fréquenté l'école
pour s'exprimer en français moi c'est là
moi c est d attirer oui et gère après
happy to beaucoup aux blessés les au
coup d'envoi rpg wii
abhisit et tu les a tuées oui mais tu
presque comme un enfant non c'est
maintenant
mais non oui même si je suis en affaires
mais il peut utiliser sa tribu comme les
appétits visé j'ai quand même une fois
cet été l'idée d'utiliser ça aurait fait
renverser celles l'ennemi sur sa famille
thomas ne veut pas s'étendre
il dit seulement que les laines doubs
ont tué son père et que là est la raison
de son engagement
thomas tient à faire visiter sa chambre
et une pièce crasseuse dans cette ville
un pilier abandonné devenue le quartier
général d'esi
il ne devrait pas en fait c'est pour
mieux nous faire admirer ces dernières
dotation le capitaine bimbo n'a un
ancien étudiant commandes le groupe
il est très fier de ses petits soldats
ils ont battus comme des grands comme
des glands même dépasser les autres
comme il sauver toutes les abeilles mais
avant ces images
ils font des choses rapidement parfois
moi je laime travail qui se sont
disciplinés mans avec les petits web
fêté à time et va c'est un âge ne sont
pas des tirs ne sont pas nous qui
regardent l'âge de ses enfants
le seul tabou is only tuerie on en
trouve dans toutes les milices mais on
sait que cette pratique est condamné par
la communauté internationale
il y avait jours c'est thomas et ses
camarades qui ont repoussé l'offensive
des laine douce urbania il ne leur font
pas peur
la présence des soldats français en
revanche les intrigues nova sénat
veulent que vous arrêtiez la guerre
ça viendra peut-être ça vient j'espère
pour toi oui ça va 100 ça va finir
peut-être tu pour aller à l'école avec
les landes ou non à l'exotisme danon qui
en préside jacques toubon le bal est
allée très quand il y aura la paix mais
ils l'aiment ne va pas laisser il perdra
l'école et le wind place aux photos
initiée par l'école chaos vénale des
piles commune iv vous égorgez une guerre
d'enfants quelque part dans la brousse
un jeune lendou du même âge nourries
sans doute au même moment la même haine
à l'égard de thomas et de ses compagnies